[Music]
what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and I have some explosive facts
for you today as we often do we had a
boat on Instagram at Anime uproar
whether the next video should be about
fumika gay or baku go and we had about
1,000 votes
thank you to everyone who voted it was
extremely close but Baku goats came out
on top with 51 percent of the votes
the cool thing about Baku go is that
he's a polarizing character people
usually have strong feelings about him
they love him or hate him but there's no
doubt that many of you are big fans and
helped make this video happen if you
like these fact videos make sure the
TExES smash that like button to let me
know also if you haven't yet - make sure
to subscribe and bring that magic
youtube bell for more my hero academia
videos let me know what fact video you
want to see next in the comments below
and it may just be the next fact video I
do now without further ado let's learn
something about the most infamous class
1a student Baku go fact number one if
you watch the previous FAQ videos I made
you probably know by now that horikoshi
puts a lot of thought into the names of
his characters they usually in one way
or another reflect the quirt personality
and/or other traits of the character in
question baku goals is one of my
favorite names because of how well it
reflects his character baku goals name
contains the kanji used in the word
explosion and the kanji used in the verb
to win obviously the word explosion
reflects his quirk and his personality
whichever way you look at it he's quick
to explode he even wanted to include
explosion in his hero name King
explosion murder which I gotta say is
probably the greatest name for a hero
I've ever heard
Batman is one thing but imagine if a guy
called King explosion murder showed up
when you were being attacked by a
villain you would be like is this guy
gonna rescue me or murder us
anyways the fact that buckles name
references winning is also perfect he's
not called Baku goat for nothing he
wants to be the best and as early as
episode 1 he says he's going to surpass
all might this guy is only talented but
works hard too he's a winner and he even
won in the UAE tournament
sometimes he isn't so victorious but
those moments are exceptions to the rule
and it hits him really hard because he
is so obsessed with being a winner with
being number one this brings us to fact
number two there is no doubt that deku
is the protagonist or main character of
my hero academia but baku go is arguably
the second most important character in
the show baka will is the second main
character or deuteragonist and I'm gonna
use Wikipedia to help define this term
because this is not one of my English
grad papers where I have to avoid the
also handy website like a medieval
plague so the deuteragonist literally
translated that second actor is the
second most important character after
the protagonist they may switch between
supporting and opposing the protagonist
depending on their own conflict or plot
baku go definitely fits the role better
than anyone else he is there from the
beginning of the story unlike the other
students of class 1a we see him as a
young kid bullying deku and see him
develop as a character and hero he is
rivals with Deku and often clashes with
him but they also have to work alongside
each other at other times like when
they're fighting villains Baku go is
completely right when he dismisses
others as an extra it's a meta moment
because they are extras and he isn't the
story spends a significant amount of
time on him and his evolution he is in
many ways like the typical protagonist
of a shounen more so than even Deku like
Naruto and Luffy he doesn't hesitate to
say that he's gonna be the number one
hero in episode 1 just like naruto says
he'll be Hokage and Luffy says he'll be
the Pirate King he's not there to
support Deku and achieving his dreams of
being a number 1 hero
quite the contrary he's there to
accomplish his own dreams which directly
can't
linked with Decker's afterdeck ooh he is
the most fleshed out character in the
story and some people are rooting for
him even more than they are rooting for
Dec fact number three Bakugan is
character if we look at how much he
changed since horikoshi initially came
up with the character if you have been
following these videos you know that
Deku was originally supposed to have
hair over his right eye but what of
course she decided to give him a haircut
baka goes changed is much more
significant believe it or not baka was
initially supposed to be a nice guy
horikoshi rights originally was still
natural-born genius
he was also airheaded enough to
inadvertently be hurting others without
any malicious intent kind of sounds like
momoyo rosu if you ask me but continue
huh Takashi then I realized that was
lame so I just went full bore and made
him explosively rotten and detestable
and I'm glad I did his face was already
built for that kind of character Wow
I don't think there's a more shocking
fact than this out there not even a kami
naughty fact could be more shocking he
was initially going to be a guy who had
a wide-eyed smile and encouraged people
to do their best and assured them that
anyone could do anything if they tried
as hoodie Cauchy points out his old self
would only piss the current Baku go off
he made a complete 180 let me know how
you feel about this change in his
character
do you paradoxically like him more as a
jerk like Claude Akashi
as we'll see in a bit he's quite a
popular character and ironically I
somehow doubt he would have been as
popular a pony cause she hadn't tried to
make him detestable now onward to fact
number four in the oracle video I asked
you guys what your favorite hero costume
was and most of you said Baku ghost
costume so let's talk about it the giant
grenade looking things on his wrists act
as storage tanks for his sweat his sweat
is the key to his quirk it acts like
nitroglycerin the more sweat the larger
his explosions will be so his explosions
are much
more powerful on hot days that cause
sweating that on cold days that don't
the storage tanks at the end of his arms
make sure that none of his sweat goes to
waste
he even has a two-stage setup to unleash
the nitroglycerin in these tanks so it
doesn't accidentally get released during
a fierce battle he must pull a pin like
a real grenade to unleash his most
fearsome explosions my personal favorite
feature is his knee pads which buckle go
had to side and I quote with the purpose
of killing with his knees as blunt
weapons only bought go would make sure
that even his knee pads can be used as
deadly weapons lastly he has hand
grenades on his belt sweat from the
storage tank is placed into these
grenades and they can be used like
normal grenades not only by Bako go but
by others as well for instance coming
out --use it before when fighting
against that guy with that gross power
to turn people into deformed clumps of
meat so yeah both ghost costume is all
about explosions death and sweat
management let me know if you guys still
think that costume is the coolest or if
you now agree with horikoshi who thinks
it's kind of gross or perhaps it can
simultaneously be considered the coolest
and grossest costume of all fact number
5 as I mentioned despite what of course
she purposely tried to make him
explosively rotten and detestable baku
goal is not only one of the most popular
characters in the show he's the most
popular character in the show at least
if we go by the latest shounen jump
popularity polls in the Japanese polls
Baku go got third that first thought
first again and the gap between Baku and
deku who got second in the latest two
polls only grew in the latest Japanese
poll deck who only beat Todoroki who got
third place by one single vote while the
gap between baka go and deku was 2,704
votes
that's insane even more so when you
consider that deku is deshone and
protagonist if we look at another Shonen
manga like one-piece luffy the main
character always gets first you
we consider that example bothwell's
popularity seems all the more impressive
in the English popularity polls baka go
got fifth and then first in the second
poll so even in the US he is extremely
popular his lowest score was in country
rolls 2018 Awards where he got 7th but
as the show catches up with the manga
there is little doubt in my mind that
both Google will start moving up once
again hot air rises after all but I'm
truly fascinated by his appeal even when
he Cauchy was shocked that Baku go
turned out to be as popular as he did
which makes sense since he set out to
make a detestable character and
paradoxically he ended up being the most
popular character instead I was thinking
of making a video about Buffalo's appeal
and exploring why he is so piper in the
future so let me know if that's
something you'd like to see in the
comments and let me know why you think
so many people like him
fact number 6 let's talk about the
inspiration from Bakugan
horikoshi actually gets inspiration from
the same place Kanye West's let me
explain Kanye West Farah movie is Akira
an anime film released in 1988 Kanye has
said that Akira is his biggest creative
inspiration although he is different
from Kanye in many ways horikoshi shares
Kanye's love of Akira in fact when asked
how he gets the gears going or in other
words the creative juices flowing what
he caught she replied that it has
nothing to do with American comic books
the secret is katsushiro Otomo's Akira
they often play the film in the office
in order to get inspired
horikoshi has further admitted that
textual a character from Akira was the
main inspiration for buckos character
they are both examples of extremely
powerful characters who nonetheless
think and act like kids in other words
they're not striving to be like
respectable and responsible adults who
conform to societal expectations the
fact that but Google has katsu in his
first name just like Otomo does is
likely another way that horikoshi pays
homage to this inspirational film and
its director so it would seem that if
horikoshi and Kanye ever had
and to run into each other they could
probably spend hours fanboying over
Akeno together fact number seven let's
talk about Bothwell stats according to
the official handbook both google has
some of the best stats in the whole show
he scored a 5 out of 5 in power a 4 out
of 5 in speed a 5 out of 5 and technique
and a 4 out of 5 in intelligence
these stats help explain how he was able
to get such amazing results so far like
rating first in the UA entrance exam
third in the cleric apprehension exam
and third in class 1s grades the latter
is a small detailing story but I love it
usually you would expect someone like
Bach go to be a delinquent who doesn't
care about school or grades but he
clearly does which adds even more
complexity to his character he's not a
super genius intellectually speaking who
can get stellar results without studying
after all he got a 4 out of 5 in
intelligence rather than someone like
Momo who got an off-the-charts 6 out of
5 Mina 2 actually has a higher
intelligence level than Baku go scoring
a 5 out of 5 yet Miata ranked 9th in
class 1a is grades this suggests that
both Google actually takes grades really
seriously and probably studies a lot the
only score that brings his total down is
cooperativeness where he scored a 1 out
of 5 but I feel like Bach Google fans
will be like who cares about
cooperativeness in fact I'd argue that
his antisocial behavior is in large part
why people love him so much in the first
place
fact number 8 Bothwell is born on April
20th which makes him a Taurus usually I
don't make a birthday it's all fact but
sometimes when I think the birth date or
horoscope reflects the character in some
significant way I like to explore the
connection such is the case with Bakugan
for instance a Taurus is and I quote
stable and conservative this is one of
the most reliable signs of the zodiac
ready to ensure and stick to their
choices until they reach the point of
personal satisfaction
now how stable Bongo is is up for debate
but he is stable and consistent when it
comes to his dreams he decided to become
the number one hero and he
stuck to that decision ever since for a
tourist what can be often seen as
stubbornness can also be interpreted as
commitment a tourist his ability to
complete tasks whatever it takes is
uncanny to me this perfectly describes
Baku go he was the first in the show to
proclaim that he will surpass all might
and he has been working as hard as
anyone if not harder ever since and I
don't think he'll ever stop until he
reaches his goal another thing is that a
Taurus is supposed to make a great
long-term friend now Baku is not easy to
make friends with by any means but I
have a feeling that him in Kirishima who
actually somehow managed to make friends
with him will be friends for a lifetime
fact number 9 Baku was voiced by 31 year
old nobuhiko okamoto he has had many
anime voice acting roles including in
blue exorcist and assassination
classroom the anime slam-dunk inspired
him to want to become a voice actor this
guy does a lot he voice act sings hosts
radio shows plays shogi and even loves
to play video games
so even baa crows voice actor is
extremely cool in the english dub baku
is voiced by the 30 year old clifford
chapman he has also voice acted in tokyo
ghoul and attack on titan among many
other anime although none of the other
characters are quite as explosive as
baku go quite the talented guy clifford
also serves as writer and director at
Funimation as always let me know if you
prefer Baku go in the sub or dub below
back number 10 if you've watched the
previous videos you know that I try to
give you bonus facts whenever possible
because who doesn't love bonus fact one
of the ways I deliver and the bonus fact
is by transforming in fact number 10
into a lightning round of facts where I
mentioned as many quick facts as I can
now let us set off a few metaphoric
explosions before we have to blow this
popsicle stand baku goal is 172
centimetres tall which is over five foot
seven and a half inches tall this puts
him right in the middle of his best
bloody eeschema and the perfect
incarnation of smarts and fanswers
momoyo toes
his blood type is a and he likes spicy
food which I expected and also
mountain-climbing
which I didn't expect but implicitly
surprised to learn and lastly there was
actually a prototype for bothwell's
character in Hawaii Co she's previous
work Omega doki zoo now as usual we go
beyond plus ultra because we roll like
that and instead of being done with the
content we now turn to the common corner
where I asked you guys on Instagram why
your favorite thing about baka go is the
response was awesome and I have never
been more curious to read your comments
as I am in this instance simply because
Baku is such a polarizing character who
you either hate or love so I can't wait
to see the reasons why some people do in
fact love this character who was
designed to be also detestable also
again a sign of how popular bak ago is
the Baku goalpost actually set a record
for the most likes we ever got in a
single Instagram post man Baku go just
breaking records once again thank you to
all of you who liked and commented and
now let's jump into some of those
comments right now a lot of you really
liked how he's not your conventional
hero for instance Libby writes
I love how devoted he is to becoming a
hero despite how he could easily be a
villain because of his anger he's just
different from all the other UA students
and I agree I also like how he stands
out when compared to the other students
and to the other heroes well at the same
time he is working as hard as anyone
else if not harder to become one when he
flat-out refused to even entertain the
idea of becoming a villain when the
League of villains kidnapped him it
showed how severely people misinterpret
his character not only in the fandom but
in the diegetic world of the show as
well
melody guest Neill likes how he doesn't
wear a tie because he's a free man to be
honest I forgot about this then went
back to the character height chart and
noticed that he was in fact the only
character now wearing a tie which is yet
another way that he stands out from the
rest and shows that he doesn't care what
others think his sagging pants also
point to this sense of freedom from
conventional norms it's impressive that
even through a strict school uniform
Bakugan still convey his personality
so well I must admit that this freedom
from societal norms and expectations on
the one hand combined with an insane
Drive and work ethic when it comes to
pursuing his dreams on the other is
probably my personal favorite thing
about Bakugan
darah cosplay along with a lot of you
mentioned his development as a character
although it comes in slow little moments
usually it's true that baku go has come
quite a long way since the days when he
and his cronies bullied Deku not only
has he learned to respect that ku more
in his own way as some of you mentioned
he actually has friends who he sees us
equals now like kitty Shima rather than
simply having cronies who follow his
orders Dara cosplay also mentions that
they like how Baku go has problems
remembering names and I'm totally the
same way so I relate to and lastly they
find it funny that BOTS Google calls
Deku a nerd even when he has better
grades I love that you brought that up
and you're right it's totally hilarious
how he tries to maintain this delinquent
ante nerd persona even while he probably
studies as hard as anyone else a lot of
you pointed out his similarities to
other popular characters
gucchi boy says he's like hasta and
naruto which is totally true in many
ways they are all loud and love making
scenes they also all proclaim their
dreams in the first episode and never
give up working on it as I mentioned
before Baku in some ways is more similar
to a conventional shorter protagonist
than Deku except for being a bully and
telling another character to kill
himself Naruto in hasta wouldn't do that
but early Regina probably would and
that's another comparison that was made
jeff says baku go is the vegeta of the
series who he hated at first but grew to
like his brand of tough love and the way
he cares for others in his own way this
is a good comparison although baku is
there from the beginning while vegeta
takes a bit especially if we count
dragon ball to make his appearance but
they both start out as tough guys who
are more talented than the main
character but eventually have to compete
with the MC and along the way become
better people solo can one simply write
Sasuke
boom which is accurate in its own way
since Baku go is a rival to the main
character as well but way more explosive
than the often stoic Sasuke yeah deal
loves his bro ship with Baku go and I've
said it before and I'll say it again
this is one of my favorite bromances in
anime to be sure let me know what your
favorite bromance in anime is below
lastly I have to include the anime dude
whose favorite MHA character is and has
always been Baku go anime dude like many
of us respects his drive to win and be
number one and he likes how Baku is
written so that his development takes
place subtly over a long period of time
without the core of his personality
which people love so much changing I
agree with that it's truly in those
little subtle moments in between his
usual antics where we see the most
development in Baku go if we look
closely enough anime dude also always
says hashtag Baku goat and I actually
heard the word from him first so if you
wash all the way to this point pay some
respect to the legend by dropping a
hashtag Baku goat in the comment and
that is it for this video I hope you
learned something new and that I did
justice to this explosive detestable and
paradoxically lovable character I have
to say that after doing this video I'm
truly fascinated by the character of
Baku go and his explosive popularity
thank you for watching especially to all
of you who regularly participate in and
watched a common corner I love hearing
your spin on the different MHA
characters it's truly a treat
although I can't put all the responses
in the video rest assured that I always
make sure to read them all make sure to
follow our instagram at anime uproar if
you want to participate and be featured
in future videos if you enjoyed this
video make sure to kill that like button
with your deadly kneepads and explode
that subscribe button and bring that
magic youtube bell with an AP shot to
make sure you never miss a new MH a
video write down who you
to see next in the comments and check
the MHA facts playlist to make sure you
don't suggest a character that's already
been done
once again thank you all so much for
your support and until next time see ya
space Cowboys
[Music]
you